i have a game recommendation though that
i found okay um it is a jrpg though all
right
it is called 13 sentinels oh i've heard
of that have you heard of that yes so i
i've found this by like complete [ __ ]
accident because i'm just like trying to
look through my game library of like
games that sound interesting
and uh i just kind of downloaded it on a
whim because i'm just like anime game
brilliant yeah somehow it's not pokemon
anymore i say that but pokemon's an
anime game
but uh yeah i download it and it is got
it has got a really [ __ ] ins
interesting concept
so the story how i can best describe
this it's like if you take boca rano and
mix that with steins gates right
so the reason you have it's called 13
sentinels is because you have like
basically you have 13 main characters
right
and so the way this story unfolds is
that you're able to select
um a perspective of part of this main
character and the basis of this is uh at
some point in the future
um
like [ __ ] kaiju come along and try to
[ __ ] destroy the world and so these
13 kids have to save the world from this
kaiju attack right but i think they fail
or something um so time travel exists
right
so you're watching you're playing this
perspective this game from like 13
different perspectives and these
perspectives like jump between timelines
and universes depending on who you
choose and you know and uh who's per sec
whose perspective you're on um and you
think this would be a complete [ __ ]
mess right like how can you tell a
coherent story when you can choose
between 13 different perspectives well
how how the game works is that you can
only progress to a certain amount of
point in one person's perspective before
you have to play another person's
perspective so one person's story
root is unlocked by playing a certain
part of another person's story roots
right so the way you would get you the
way you get delivered the story is like
little by little and you get to piece
together what the [ __ ] has happened
between
this entire [ __ ] timeline it's
actually like insane it's cool yeah like
i remember yeah i remember my my twitch
chat like telling me all about it be
like you'd [ __ ] love this good
ratings it does have good ratings that's
that's that's kind of that's kind of why
aegis rim
oh it's an atlas game of course that's
why it's good
of course yeah
yeah so so the gameplay is kind of like
kind of like a turn-based strategy it's
like
the the best way i can describe it like
it looks gorgeous yeah that looks cute
it looks really cute yeah it is a very
atlas game i realized because it's
basically a mix between a visual novel
but with gameplay elements to break up
the story of that visual novel switch
versions coming out in april this year
okay
but uh i i highly recommend that because
that was just a that was that was just
something i played on the whim because
like i said i give everything like
two hours or something try and grab me
and this one like grabbed me immediately
it has a very original storytelling
method and uh
i'm about halfway through and like they
use like some of the twists and turns
i've seen in the story are like [ __ ]
insane atlas don't miss me yeah yeah i
really don't miss yeah so except their
new catherine game that was [ __ ]
i i know more about the memes of the
catherine game than actual actual people
that have played catherine i played the
new character in game and it was it was
not that good
because it's weird because like a lot of
atlas games just i hear more about the
japanese side talking about it but like
i'd hardly ever hear anyone in the
western hemisphere talking about it
unless it's persona yeah that's because
that's basically the western hemisphere
or the western the western world the
western i don't know why i said well i
don't know why i said hemisphere there
is a japan in the western hemisphere
technically anywhere
depending on where you are
i kind of realized that
yeah yeah i feel like yeah
i feel it's because like in the west
it's like very it's a very core fan base
for these games you know yeah yeah
because they are like
the jrpg players jrpgs a lot of people
like anime game no thank you yeah
exactly yeah they take monkey yeah
rightfully
yeah they take one look at the the
visuals or like the concept and they're
just like nope
i'd rather play bang bang bang
look at this man
i understand you know there's a certain
kind of
expectation that comes with anime games
that in my experience is always the same
yeah you always get that same feeling
yeah even if the stories are different
the gameplay is different something
about it just always comes off as the
same in my mind i don't know i don't
know
i don't fault people after thinking that
that's what i like about it yeah that's
consistency yeah i don't fault people
for thinking that though because that's
exactly how i feel with a lot of fps
games yeah where it's like the concept
is different but at the end of the day
it's still bang bang bang yeah yeah so i
i don't it's fine i but rpgs for me but
like even like western driven story
driven games as well it's just like i
don't know i i guess it's the same
reason why i'm into anime versus movies
and tv shows i mean i will always watch
a movie and tv show but those aren't the
core pieces of entertainment that i like
for example like
i play i've been playing the last of us
and it's a great game but i just have
like zero emotional attachment to it
like right i i play it and i can like
objectively view you as a anime huh
because they're not anime i i guess i
don't know if they were more anime you'd
be like i care
i don't know why it was just
it's the way western storytelling works
is that it's it's it's it's got like
different tropes and a different method
of storytelling but
i don't know why i gravitate more to
like the anime style of storytelling
because i i do think they do have a
different style
yeah different different cultures and
everything like that and you know the
way joel and ellie were written as
characters were great they they were
great characters i just
i don't know i just didn't
emotionally attach myself to either of
those characters even though i could
tell that they were great characters why
do you emotionally attach yourself more
to anime characters then
because he's a weeb
right like what what about the way that
they do their characters is more
appealing i think it's because they're
unrealistic i i was going to say because
that's what bothers me yeah
i i like the fact that with anime
characters there's like a clear
distinction
between reality and fantasy right and i
like having that easy separation in my
mind where you can have great
really well written anime characters
that are still clearly like really
[ __ ] unrealistic like just take any
[ __ ] tsundere for example you can
have great written cinderellas but at
the end of the day if you meet a real
[ __ ] real live singer you're just
gonna think that they're they're a [ __ ]
and
why why are they putting like why are
they doing domestic violence on their
like partner or whatever right do you
think that the authors who are like
writing these are intentionally making
unrealistic characters or they that's
like they're they're intending to do
real characters but it just comes off as
unrealistic
i think it's i think it's all based on
just like not only like the cultural
understanding and like norm of that
author but it's also the fact that a lot
of these authors are also hashing off
other japanese creations and other
japanese characters right so yes you
know that like i i don't really know of
many or any like japanese author who
takes direct influence from like western
stuff for example yeah right like the
only one i can think of is like [ __ ]
iraqi yeah you know which is why his
characters are so [ __ ] different
compared to the traditional norm like
manga anime character character yeah not
just like visually but also like
as like a characteristic of that
particular person right yeah like why
why is like so many anime set in high
school why is that like is that a
cultural thing it's a cultural thing why
why so it's because it's for a lot of
people
like high school is kind of seen as like
this basically like golden time it's
depressing
it's like for a lot of people high
school is like you know the whole thing
of like in the west of like high school
is like you know usually movies that are
based in high school in the west are
based off bad memories yeah you know
being like oh man my high school [ __ ]
sucked blah blah blah there were all
these [ __ ] people the jocks the bullies
blah blah blah right that's the norm in
the west in japan it's glorified because
to a lot of people high school was a
really fun time with like friends
they'll never get back and like yeah
because it's also the last years of that
person being young and free i mean i
like high school but i wouldn't say i
like my life
yeah yeah i think as well in terms of
like a storytelling like standpoint as
well like i feel like kids in high
school or like kids going through
puberty
is just already a really interesting
like character dynamic like you can like
you can get characters to get away with
a lot of [ __ ] just because they're in
puberty yeah but i feel like there are
so many [ __ ] shows and so many anime
where you look at the characters and
they could be in any [ __ ] setting oh
yeah yeah cause like some of the [ __ ]
that these high schoolers go through
they like go through like two world wars
they're like like they're like like
fighting avengers level threats when
they've reached the [ __ ] 13 years old
and you're probably not a well-written
character yeah that's that's clearly
just an author being like i like high
school settings let's put them in high
school you know but don't actually take
full advantage of it unfortunately but
there's a lot of authors that take full
advantage of like the high school
characters and that whole setting and
actually like work it into their
characters and story mind you
that's the minority in my opinion a lot
of them are just like high school
realistic uh relatable with audience am
i right let's just throw them in there
you know i watched uh the gretzko the
new season oh it's good that was good
very refreshing yeah depressing as
always depressing as [ __ ] yes which is
great to see because it's like one of
the only anime out there that will
actually like commentate
on adult life in japan and be realistic
about yeah
but it also says a lot when it no one
knows about in japan yeah is that true
it is absolutely it is absolutely
unknown in japan oh [ __ ] yeah like it is
not popular at all probably
[Music]
very japanese things in it as well it's
so japanese but like it's such a good
take on the japanese workflow awesome
how awful it is yeah yeah because like i
mean
it's ironic that this has come from the
same company that you know made hello
kitty yeah
just to put it into perspective like how
deep they're going so in japan right
they have a thing called uh say shine
right
yeah which is like an employee for life
yeah you can't you can never fire this
employee they have to do something like
really [ __ ] right they have to leave
on their own right but like even the
only way they can get fired is if they
actually do something like illegal right
right
the only way they can leave them you
cannot by going to jail you could
literally do the shittiest job on earth
like you could like not turn up and you
cannot be fired right yeah so in japan
obviously because they decided job
security so yeah
so
obviously if you told that to anyone in
any western country they'd be like i
don't think that sounds like a good idea
because it's not because it's not it's
not like let's just be honest obviously
job security is good and you know that's
that's good but like it's a terrible
idea for any business right like you
need you need to be able to get rid of
employees yeah yeah of course but
obviously in the west you know it's a
little uh
especially in some places they're a
little too happy to fire employees yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you know it has to be
a balance because it's a balance there's
a whole
arc or like story in the new season i
won't spoil who it is or what it is but
there's a character who uh because they
can't fire him uh they just relocate him
to some [ __ ] and they don't give him
any work yeah and they basically just
like morally make him want to quit yeah
yeah yeah and it's a whole thing and
it's pretty [ __ ] dope that's the only
way that says shane can quit yeah so
they basically just pressure them yeah
they bully you yeah they bully you
quitting yeah so so there's a whole
thing where they like just make him [ __ ]
off and like make him you know because
obviously people are people don't wanna
people wanna be valued right when they
do work right and if you're just not
doing anything you're going to be like
why am i here yeah obviously if i was
there i'd be like fantastic i can catch
up fantastic let's uh let's just play
apex that's why it works in japan
i'm like are you telling me i can just
do whatever i want
and you're going to give me the salary
what's going on
maybe that's for the battle yeah true
true but yeah they go to some really
dark stuff and it's a shame that it's
not being japanese i feel like it could
make waves maybe it's too real i think
it is i think it's just purely the fact
that you know a japanese person will
look at that and be like i don't want to
see this because it's just going to
remind me of a reality and uh to a lot
of japanese people that's not the reason
why they're watching there's not really
one [ __ ] dark bit i mean i think i'm
sure you can remember it in the new
season right can i spoil it i won't say
who it is i'll just say what happens
oh no no i know what you're talking
about yeah maybe we should you can't say
this
really is it that bad it's a it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a twist all right
yeah yeah
just watch later season it's [ __ ]
amazing honestly
is like killing it i've had mixed mixed
reviews about the fourth season actually
some people have said that it feels like
it's
said everything it's needed to say now
and it's getting like it's like they're
trying a lot
to like bring something new on the table
uh first five episodes really good yeah
last five episodes boring [ __ ] like
completely unnecessary i didn't like it
that's how i felt yeah i felt like they
had a good thing going
and then they just definitely it fizzles
out at the end yeah right right but it's
still a solid season though